hi my name is Rashmi and I'm an actress
and screenwriter and I started to write
to create more work for myself and also
because I'm very interested in what's
happening in the world in terms of
radicalization and the forms it takes in
different societies including our own my
screenplay is called a divide and I
specifically focus on terrorism the
logline being a counter-terrorist agent
discovers that her brother is the prime
suspect in a terrorist plot so with this
background of global terrorism I follow
that story through the lens of a brother
and sister who when they were children
were very close and then are torn apart
by by terrorism in that one of them
radicalize 'as and the other is trying
to stop him and the sister is a cop and
so I really wanted to get into how this
affects people on a personal level you
know some of the effects which we've you
know we've we've experienced here in the
states with 911 and then you know
wanting to explore that further on a on
a personal and familial and a
relationship level and also the reasons
behind medicalization so I've been
working on it for about four years I do
really believe in it I think it's very
urgent and timely it has a female
protagonist on it I you know I really
believe in it and I and it actually
becomes more and more relevant and my
goal is to see it fully realized and to
act in it and to have it be an effective
dramatic thriller that tells the story
of these very close siblings torn apart
through global terrorism well one of the
things that screenwriting has taught me
is that do not be afraid of the unknown
you know if you just keep doing it your
questions will be answered and the
things will come even though you think I
really don't know what to do next if you
just keep at it you get really
comfortable with the unknown and in fact
you kind of start looking forward to it
because you
really don't know what's going to happen
and then you just take that next step
and you also get really used to little
steps when do I write are usually right
in the morning and sometimes on the
weekends i'll take huge chunks of time
and right i find that to be very
effective especially with rewriting or
go away and just you know lock myself in
a room and do that and yeah that's
that's that's it i'm the writer of the
divide and my name is Rashmi and thank
you for doing this